I lost 32 followers on Facebook this
might be my biggest challenge I've ever
had I'm super super nervous just like to
tell everybody that I love them and I
hope I get through this with Donald
Trump really be that bad
I'm not usually one for bets but if I
was going to put money down I would bet
on Trump the one candidate that seems
least likely to pander to outside groups
is Trump that's pretty good
I lost four followers yeah I did it's
already got oh so I'm lost eight
Facebook followers so far I've lost six
Facebook forwards you're not gonna
believe it but I'm actually gaining
followers so far I've lost 14 followers
13 likes on status though I just got a
frantic text message from one of my
friends demanding answers just got a
text from my girlfriend because our
friend texted her asking if I was
serious or not starting to legitimately
feel bad
oh my god Facebook notification I just
prayed this was a bad idea
by the end of the day I was down 31
followers
I lost 32 followers there are people in
this world that think I will vote for
Donald Trump a surprising number of my
friends like the status a few people
called me out for trolling and then I
started to get like people I haven't
spoken to since college most of them
were angry at me a lot of people yelled
at me other people yelled at other
people it was a typical Facebook
argument I would like to apologize to my
facebook followers I'm sorry i deceived
you I'm sorry I bet I did something that
wasn't really funny